how to slice and dice a data set
most of the time the data you work with
won't be perfectly prepared for training
models
in this video we'll explore various
features that the datasets library
provides to clean up your data
the datasets library provides several
built-in methods that allow you to
wrangle your data in various ways
in this video we'll see how you can
shuffle and split your data select the
rows you're interested in
tweak the columns and apply processing
functions with the map method
let's start with shuffling
it is generally a good idea to place
shuffling to your training set so that
your model doesn't learn any artificial
ordering the data
if you want to shuffle the whole data
set you can apply the appropriately
named shuffle method
you can see an example of this method in
action here where we've downloaded the
training split of the squad data set and
shuffled all the rows randomly
another way to shuffle the data is to
create random train and test splits
this can be useful if you have to create
your own test splits from raw data
to do this you just apply the trained
test split method and specify how large
the test split should be
in this example we specify that the test
set should be 10 of the total data set
size
you can see that the output of the train
test split method is a dataset dict
object whose keys correspond to the new
splits
now that we know how to shuffle the data
set let's take a look at returning the
rows we're interested in
the most common way to do this is with
the select method
this method expects a list or a
generator of the dataset's indices and
will then return a new dataset object
containing just 30 rows
if you want to create a random sample of
rows you can do this by chaining the
shuffle and select methods together
in this example we've created a sample
of five elements from the squad data set
the last way to pick out specific rows
in a data set is by applying the filter
method
this method checks whether each row
fulfills some condition or not
for example here we've created a small
lambda function that checks whether the
title starts with the letter l once we
apply this function with the filter
method we get a subset of the data just
containing these rows
so far we've been talking about the rows
of a data set but what about the columns
the datasets library has two main
methods for transforming columns
a rename column method to change the
name of the column and a remove columns
method to delete them
you can see examples of both these
methods here
some datasets have nested columns and
you can expand these by applying the
flattened method
for example in the squad data set the
answers column contains a text and
answer start field
if we want to promote them to their own
separate columns we can apply flatten as
shown here
now of course no discussion of the
datasets library would be complete
without mentioning the famous map method
this method applies a custom processing
function to each row in the dataset
for example here we first define a
lowercase title function that simply
lowercases the text in the title column
and then we feed that function to the
map method and voila we now have
lowercase totals
the map method can also be used to feed
batches of rows to the processing
function
this is especially useful for
tokenization where the tokenizers are
backed by the tokenizers library and
they can use fast multithreading to
process batches in parallel
you